this video is sponsored by liquid IV
more on them after the reaction
people
bonjour I Really Work to remember that
we are here today it is John and Greg in
the hot seats to watch Ridley Scott's
Napoleon a topic a figure of History we
both know a ton about are you excited G
I am so excited I've watched every movie
Napoleon's ever made I've read all of
his books I've bought his art I know
everything about him I'm going to p on
this PO s is what I meant to say yeah
yeah absolutely me too I'm excited to
watch French Joker so hey leave a like
on this video also don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to get notified every time one of these
movies comes your way as well thanks to
the gang over at prepper for helping us
chop down these highlights and if you
want to get the complete Napoleon
experience all six hours of it alongside
Greg and myself come on over to
patreon.com theal rejects grab your own
copy sync up with us enjoy the movie as
well as all the other shows and movies
we have watch alongs and highlights for
over there it's a blast it's a good time
and I think that's all the
housekeeping let's go let's let's go to
France let's do this
thing
did you see a tra for this I didn't see
a tra for it nope I've heard a couple
reviews like vague like just like oh it
was good or not but yeah otherwise
no
1789 man I Don't Know Jack about
Napoleon nope people are tuned to misery
to Revolution and brought back by
Revolution to misery ni we said French
have disillusioned by food shortes and
widespread economic depression haha
anti-royalist would soon send King Louie
the 16th and 11,000 of his supporters to
a violent end and set their sights in
the queen of FR missed it missed
something about Queen let him eat
cake packs a thud is that the
guillotine oh even just the sound effect
imagine going out that way that's Kirby
in
this
WOW
sheeps was a simpler time
boy she's just being treated like the
ex-wife of every celebrity yeah this is
what she deserves
yeah off with her head off off off oh is
that song about Marie Anto yep
yep you can learn most of the plot of
this movie just by listening to the y
[Applause]
y I do like the music being very much in
contrast with the horrendous Terror
that's about to take place for this poor
individual or do I not like her I don't
I don't know yeah does she just she have
this coming was she detached from oo
feels so real will and needs of her
people I know they never focus on that
part where they're sliding the brace
down you know the human head lives for
several seconds after it is decapitated
that's what I'm looking forward to in
life sweet
sauce oh cool let them eat
stump oh there's your
boy
feels Quirk quirky yeah now she was
guilty of three charges against you and
high treason for acting in the interests
of the enemy sheep yeah she deserved to
have her head cut off the British Navy
have taken the port of tulong half the
French Fleet is trapped there if we lose
those ships the Republic will fall well
we can't let that happen there are only
2,000 English troops in tul we are short
of artillery and led by a general who
was a court pain who it's an idiot it is
not necessary to recapture tulon itself
the town is not a town the town is a
port homeboy is not even attempting an
accent
NOP this is going to be one of those
every Accent movies I think capture the
fort that dominates the harbor and you
have the city we must make an example
our other cities will fall and I for one
will never let the royalists or the
English take my region yeah no surrender
it's good
response man when it comes to sets and
stuff red Le Scott knows how to hire the
right people every
time Luc and my dear brother I'm in too
loan already and it
sucks going to need a lot more cannons
this looks like a really fun set to be
on if we do not
succeed those in power will only see us
as corsan Ruffians unfit for higher
office and our mother's Ambitions will
be quashed and corkin Ruffians are no
bueno yeah bad ombr I got to simplify
some of this for my brain surprise is my
advantage but I will win by fire I
cannot wait for your arrival your
brother Nao win by fire that is a way to
end a letter so he's scouting this seen
right now in disguising himself as just
a regular civilian yeah the classical
music provides a bit of like a Whimsical
tone that I wasn't
expecting and I mean the film does have
like a classical feeling sort of sense
of scope and and just I don't know the
way they're lensing everything and the
austerity of a lot of the Landscapes and
stuff
drink and always bring people together
no matter where you are in the world and
what
time Napoleon seems so terrified right
now so nervous it's a big Revolt I mean
he's making his rise he's not Napoleon
just
yet breathe Napolean you got this
man
flying by the seat of his
pants
[Applause]
whoa ah cool it's one thing we can all
relate to is rebelling against the
British I miss this kind of action in
cinema his expression are great keep it
[Music]
together man all these stun workers and
Extras get the up
there what a fun set the explosions
happening on on the actual
stage what the [__] oh I that was not
expected yeah what kind of movie are we
in that was extremely violent David A's
Napoleon David A's your reference sure
I'll take a David a Napoleon why we just
watched Fury
the there's Battlefield horse Gore you
know very realistic depictions you're
not used to
seeing get up there
Napoleon team Napoleon
yeah that's what you're supposed to take
away from all
this oh my
god oh
sweet I want to start a counter of how
many heads get lopped off across
[Music]
[Applause]
this
damn it's so weird to see him without
his hat
on
Jesus wow cool this some cool violence I
know ready to get him yes sir oh look at
him he's coming into his own he's
focused
yeah come on
Napoleon
you know he did job this is a beautiful
looking
film
woo thieving Pirates great
shot this is a very whoa very striking
time period aesthetically always damn
they really built all these ships I
guess maybe maybe they Miniatures some
of them
but beautiful wow you can like feel the
Flames what a formation Napoleon buap I
award you the rank of Brigadier
General my
man do we like Napoleon we love Napoleon
okay who's your favorite French dictator
comment below he's a dictator eventually
not yet though okay now he's just the
commander or
whatever I promised you brilliant
successes and I've kept my word
brilliant success although it is a
little confusing that we just defeated
the British and half of these French
Dudes at British
accents I'm happy for you
buddy that was a really well done
sequence because it is fraught and dark
as it was it was still able to keep up
with everything that was going on and it
does like dip in and out of just like
the chaos of war in this point in time
where it is so personal and just like
people up against each
[Music]
other for mother Jesus Christ for mother
what kind of mother did you have the
current leadership of France has passed
from enthusiasm to Reckless ambition and
the public perception of the guillotine
his Lawless passion my ROP spear oh he
is unfit to Ru robes Pierre has a rep
throughout history for sure is Napoleon
asleep
yep my man there is no man in this room
who has objected to my methods if you
say I am guilty you are all guilty oh
that's what I say in my relationship
only I can fix
thisr arrest
him well they just come to that how
fragile the rule of law
is that dude just doing like a people's
elbow back
there yes was my tiny
gun
whoa yeah
coward oh my God
a guillotine my friend I thought he was
going to be like it's real all right
it's blood son of a
[__] I know it's just a time and place
but when you do [__] like that it just
keeps reminding me of
pirates end of the reign of terror are
we about to celebrate bastile day or
something here every French viewer of
this video is going to be like typing in
the comments Non-Stop
the movie should do a good enough job
communicating what's happening without
us having to read a history book that's
that's true if it's a good enough
adaptation of the novel you
know
wow like an ancient
witch
Rider
[Music]
gadriel uh I saw the opening scene that
is not an accurate
depiction it's starting to come back to
me she was very out of touch with the
needs of her people from what I recall
vaguely from history the irony of the
let the famous let them me
[Music]
cake in true classic theater fashion no
women on the stage
Savage I mean it is highlighting how
thin the barriers between savagery and
civility are yeah people complain about
comedy today
yeah just walking in the room looking
like Joe Pera hello my name is Napoleon
and I'm going to lead us to Victory you
know we're in France baby no sense of
human decency we're in the enlightened
part of the world all right we're in
Bohemia
Prime damn she looks way different with
that why you staring at me Liz Salander
hair am
I I was not oh you w she said yes before
he said no I was
not I was star at your face face at your
face what is this costume you have all
this is my uniform I let the French
victory at too long he just wanted to
drop that line tonight yeah you were
just waiting for anyone who would listen
do not tell me your name I will guess it
give me 200 chances yes like that while
this is high society everyone's still
like a little sweaty and like Caked Up
like it looks like the real version of
high society you're a young man who
wishes to see you his name is yenan name
oh Easter egg oh he's from the first one
what do you want my father's saber it
was taken from him before he was
arrested and executed we need new Kaiba
crystals I cannot allow citizens to have
weapons in their possession the sword is
a Keepsake for me to remember my dear
late father perhaps but it as a weapon
nevertheless how do people like prepare
food my mother said that you were the
only Dem man of authority to retrieve
the sword who's the
mother that
light all of these are from officers who
were sentenced to die did no one think
to attach names to any of them no there
are no names damn find a needle in a
needle stack take the most Rusty
one kid going to be like this isn't it I
know the sword anywhere he does have a
very relaxed presence on in this time
period like he he fits in in a way that
normally people be a little more pushed
in the way they behave thank
you there she is yeah you knew it
there's the majer my compliments to the
chef of this fine family he's
hallucinating
[Music]
her is he touching himself right now is
this his fantasy yeah clunk clunk clunk
clunk would you like to St
[Music]
closer did they intentionally make him
shorter maybe I know that's a debated
part of the actual history as to like
whether he was actually short or if
people just did that to taint His Image
later oh it's a
date will you be my boyfriend yes
no maybe what did he just too he's just
being sensitive you know she probably
perfumed
it Napoleon wouldn't be Napoleon if it
wasn't for her
yeah this is real love right here
chemistry unmatched when you look at me
do you see an aristocrat or an
aristocat no my husband had more than
one lover and when his head was cut off
all his Mistresses watched she weren't
alone when I was in prison I I was told
the only way to survive was to get
pregnant yes wow do I need to warn you
of my
indiscretions no Madam I don't give a
[__] just where I have been concern you
pastes the past well like how many were
we talking here like
ballpark of course if you look down
you'll see a surprise once you see it
you will always want it
this works yes Mommy this
works people of France don't be fooled
there are more of us it's fascinating
can occupy this convention this movie is
framed like paintings but it doesn't
behave like a
[Applause]
painting no doubt you've seen the chaos
in the streets yes can you hear it yeah
it's like happening right at these new
windows are really soundproof there is a
belief amongst the committee that there
is an attack on the council coming by
this mob I have less than 4,000 troops
and very little in the way of weapons
there are 40 cannons in Sablon I could
have them here in 3 hours this mob is
20,000 strong yes you don't need to take
down all 20,000 though what would you
intend to do if this assignment of
defense was transferred to
you uh tread carefully I accept on the
condition that I command this as I see
fit without interruption in devastating
Victory via my water
slide royalist Insurrection fifth
October
1795 just get it done Napoleon
yeah let's go what a harrowing ass
shot The Emptiness in those
eyes wipe them out Napoleon
3 hours
later
[Applause]
wow wow
wow who your foot I mean you had to get
the job done it's true somebody had to
make the tough decisions Marie Joseph
Rose Tash except as her husband Napoleon
bonapart Dynamite do you consider
yes I do I'm already like very
suspicious of how accurate this love
story is yes it seems like the very
Hollywood thing to do the whole here's
who he was as he rose the ranks and
became the dictator we all know and love
and then we have the love story like but
here's where he was a human yeah and the
love story while I am intrigued does
feel like the the most elevated or
Fantastical part thus far but I'd love
to be wrong of the Republic Madam Bon
mad Bon hey here
here kill that man this I'm going
Napoleon side man if we're going to
watch us through his lens I am going to
experience it rooting for him yeah this
movie is an endorsement of all of his
views and
actions dude dude a with your
breasticles hanging out like that don't
be getting jealous dog you said you were
going to get jealous if I see my wife
talk to another man I think about that
for a long time and contemplate doing
something hi so for those watching the
YouTube cut Napoleon's trying very hard
to satisfy his woman yeah and she looks
um not moved At All by this
experience after that love making scene
I really see myself in Napoleon man yeah
man pull that bone apart just like I
know what it's like what
yeah I follow Alexander the Great and
Caesar as I've have been sent to
liberate Egypt I have 40,000 men and the
sights are wondrous and the weather
stifling hot sure plan for attacking
England through their Eastern Empire
that's what I'm talking about but my
achievement seem slight as they keep us
apart I mean Napoleon might not be
physically small in this movie but he
does have an inferiority complex sure
massively so wow the freaking pyramids
dude
dude oh my God man's got to do what a
man's got to do that's right that's
right no matter how wonderful the world
dear wife this love I have for you is a
kind of death a little death yes Petty
more there's no survival for me except
in you hell again what are you
doing good morning Luc if you love me
you me twice a day who are you doing
tell me there are no snakes in your bed
in your legs inside what is
mine write me and tell me that you
realize that I love you beyond the
limits of imagination chea of which I
have much you cheat on a great man like
this
yeah a great
man wow all the locations and I I really
feel like you can feel the weather in
each scene you cut to I know and then it
makes it all the more fascinating that
Ridley Scott shoots like four movies a
year and then they still feel like
completely entrenched in where they are
there's a lot of like film making
technical Marvel on
display with consistent pensive music
that plays yes with a hint of
irony
whoa tip
toing give me PA get me an Apple box
damn respect oh I got a little bit of a
haircut give him a Wet
Willie I want to do that thing's going
to
disintegrate What secrets did it whisper
to you from Beyond the Grave are there
limits
to what I can tell you only you create
the limits no shouldn't be should I tell
you something at the risk of giving you
personal pain he's going to find out his
wife is cheating your wife has taking a
lover named eite Charles what a name too
why would you cheat on this guy troops
we're moving out we got to go get my
wife this guy's like I told Napoleon he
just left my fault he didn't believe me
he said go for it do more more lovers
you expect me to believe this yes and my
wife would do this to
me yes no dessert for you you may
leave punish
him I wouldn't like my dessert please ah
yeah what a great
frame you think that was intentional yes
like is this the master lucil is my
lover she writes to me Josephine's lady
in waiting is your lover strategic
Choice prepare two frigs and two smaller
vessels in the greatest secrecy I'm
returning
home no you shouldn't be seen as
desertion why did you tell him now you
should have waited yeah dude General c
will be informed of his succession to
command after I left man she's ruining
the war yeah come on dude keep your head
in the game you changed bro you Chang
she's just like every ex celebrity's
wife or current wife when celebrity is
having
downfall oh my God made the
headlines wow it has oh my God and a
cartoon to boot this is not going to
bode well for his inferiority complex
damn dude they leaked the texts if I was
him I'd start with the children yeah and
from
yeah punishment's all around where's my
wife she has left to greet you in Leo
whoa dude where is my wife Jesus she
left earlier today General Leon yes sir
the entire world knows of my arrival but
not my
wife such a little boy such a little boy
so petulant yeah she's terrified for her
life oh she grown her hair out too to
demonstrate the passage of time John
yeah or she put on a
wig Oh no you're lucky he's just kicking
you out man he could easily behead you
yeah and he did pack your [__] what kind
of creature are you how could you care
so little for me and my
feelings you are a selfish little
pig wow not try to touch his hand sorry
a that's not enough I wouldn't forgive
this man I want you to say that I am the
most important thing in the world yeah
wow I relate with this guy so uh never
mind you're the most important thing in
my life and without me you are nothing
I'm nothing and you will do anything
I'll do anything wow this is like
watching us on screen I'll do anything
like we've had this exact conversation
yeah
and then we turned the camera on and
started shooting
Theo you're a
beast oh man he's just going to put you
down forever you're a freaking Beast bro
I feel sorry for you oh my God this is a
fireside chat you want to be
great you are nothing without me say it
wow the power
oh I mean he's got like clear mom
problems he took the cannon out of the
horse and gave it to to her yeah yeah do
you love me yet you are just a brute
that is nothing without me I just a
brute that is nothing without you yes
let's go how can you be on her side
symolon you sad sad little boy did you
have a fast of course I did well yeah
but that's different
did you love
them no no I did not oh okay never mind
they could be on our he literally left
the war to come home and talk about this
were they pretty yes some of them some
of them who more than I do they cried
less that made them more
attractive
bars
yep
just
you don't have to forgive me just
promise me you are be sometimes it's
easier just to stay in the toxic
relationship man these two are made for
each other what is it that made you
desert your troops in Egypt my wife was
Bowman boning a man boning while we were
apart what country are we in because she
doesn't resemble the France that I left
who should be responsible for her
governance while I'm
away because it is not you citizen go
wait way to flip this my man
this it's not you certainly you are you
truthfully you're very good at scowling
it's not you baras or you ton or you SE
I'm going to remember all their names
yeah yeah that one guy opens a diner
later on I have returned to France to
find her bankrupt printing money that is
spent within hours chapter 11 ostr
Russian overrun of Italy the
anglo-russian occupation of Holland and
what appears to be the IM an invasion of
France herself well we cannot let that
happen no someone's got to fix this and
yet you accuse me of desertion oh my God
great that's right man you take the take
control of the situation there is
there's a lot to learn from this man the
people will accept my rule if I have
your support like you that I believe
that the directory is corrupt Trin that
swamp but together we can save this
country from a restoration of the
monarchy and we can preserve the ideals
of the Revolution and I think that a
seizure of power is possible oh good so
you expect me to be your sword more than
that I expect that a kudeta well timed
well executed could transfer power into
the hands of three consols yep myself du
and G and you
boom I'm inviting you to The Winning
Side oh yeah do that that'll show your
wife that'll show your wife and your mom
letter of resignation I'm not signing
anything you can piss before I sign
anything wow look at those murals my
God I'm going to make this very simple
for you oh good I have documents
announcing your resignation from the
council I feel like Paul and him were
cool yeah citizen Mulan We have a letter
of resignation for you to sign oh I am
enjoying a succulent breakfast this
isang i f finished my breakfast before
you catch
me oh it's
okay you fly away you're free now go get
out of
here the coup at Christmas this is a
very interesting tone this emergency
session is to draw a list of number n
minations for a a new directory to deal
with the threat all right let's get it
going we are being asked to pass a
resolution forming a provisional
government to three councils yes and we
have three of mine General bonapart and
citizen CZ and rer du where are the five
members of the directory please stand up
your brother Napoleon bonapart with his
show of military might is acting as an
outlaw pull it together Napoleon pull it
together Napoleon no
enough there
is wow man viated
the
wow damn wow you can really feel the
camera here yeah oh my God the first
time I became aware of a camera yeah I
know
right whoa fing Phoenix really do that
sure looked like he did I believe he
would throw himself into
that there
go oh my God walking Phoenix with his
funny Escapist runs we are being
terrorized by deputies armed with
daggers and these Mad Men have outl
themselves godamn right way to Twisted
on the liberty of this country who is
this guy I've seen him in stuff they're
trying to kill me they're trying to kill
him Jesus yeah there's so like actual
comedy in this movie oh this is
absolutely like a comedy dressed like an
auster history you know piece that like
this is lowkey hilarious there's a
there's a black comedy here it's really
really odd strange it's cor quirky as
[__] well it's got all like the posture
and import of like you know the weight
you associate with history but it's also
highlighting yeah just how Petty and
small so many of these people are
shall we vote shall we vote my
manad style points for
days oh
[Music]
yeah there some soundproof
[Applause]
doors and just like how flippant the
people in charge are with like all the
stuff that dictates life to the people
below like good to meet
you is that his
Mommy ah could this be Joseph oh they
haven't met yet Josephine good to see
you
Josephine oh it's Charles immediately
disinterested finally get to meet your
daughter-in-law and no interest mom but
but did you did you see Mom what about
what I need from you is a better
understanding of the Russian Zar
Alexander would you consider the Zar an
ally to England or France his trade with
England is more beneficial to him than
his trade with France and you have a
sense of British influence in the
Russian courts uh-oh I do not but I
imagine it is quite robust
robust explain this word robust what
kind of man is he describ him what does
he look like well he's young is he hot
he's vain he's popular and he wishes to
remain so statue right behind him
greatest fear is to be killed in his bed
like his
father this makes him dangerously fickle
to whoever last has his attention he run
the m city they knowbody he check the
lock every time you walk by the
door tand your majesty received a letter
of peace from the first counil today
peace over to us are clearly only for
you all handling a French public opinion
wowe but my warning to you is that he's
as hungry for it as any man in the
history of the world so my suggestion
would be to take little offering of
peace from him it's no little offering
man yeah or suffer the consequences for
a man bent on peace at any
cost where's John Cena they know how to
Veil their threats in such clever ways I
know I wonder how many people like left
all these different conversations like
not getting the undertone I think he was
threatening me are you aware of my
letter of peace to your king I am not
shall I repeat it you may not take this
as a warning to your king I will keep
you guessing you will watch your borders
and your back and your manners are bound
sooner or later to be French bam and I
will take the lack of a swift reply as
an act of disrespect you think you're so
great because you have
[Music]
both I want to say that to
somebody she's so good at playing
Manchild yeah seriously so good at that
plays it quite a
bit developmentally stunted that would
be the type cast I would play for
walking Phoenix sure Manchild the
European families think nothing more of
you than a Corsican Thug uhoh I suggest
that you're abandon your role as first
counil of France why would you think
this wouldn't make him mad for the title
Victorious counil by another name King
wow bring the monarchy back baby king
who decided these hats they all wear he
could become king yeah you could just
make it so I guess just change the
structure around a little bit you know
the blueprint it's already
exists my hair has been set the way you
like
it
what
beautiful
come what is
is he like clopping like a like a horse
[__] it's yours thank you thank
you it's the most unflattering scenes
just the dispassionate scenes they have
here yeah it's like meat hitting other
meat that's it like there's no real
chemistry here why aren't you pregnant
uh-oh is that a question that an
accusation yes it was a
question now it's an accusation now it's
an accusation God that little dip he
took with her chair what I've seen Dr CA
and he has no answer well maybe you got
to get on top yes the gravity you do a
headstand afterwards along with hopeful
thinking and a bit of red wine I
suggested I take the waters at EXA
Chapelle and what happened you as wife
of the first console I haven't found the
time I spend many hours cleaning up
after you yep imagine doing this as
Queen queening up after me I don't need
to explain to you the importance of this
do I what you want an a I want one
now my God show me how the piggies eat
at least he's so playful with her oh my
God it is the one way in which she seems
to
play Napoleon not have children maybe
not he didn't have a nappo
baby Vanessa Kirby man she's got that
Elegance yeah oh he was allowed to
attend this damn dude president poing
didn't do anything about him may God
affirm you on his throne and Christ give
you to rule with him in his ATT
Kingdom this guy knows a lot about
Christ the King I can do whatever I want
and with his Caesar Halo I found the
crown of France in the gutter I picked
it up with the tip of my sword and
cleaned it and placed it at top my own
head King wears a King hat and sits on a
king
chair not a thick ass Crown damn yeah
how do you how how do you be stacking
these crowns with these Tiaras and the
most AUST
Napoleon is crown and inro long live the
emperor live the emperor
[Applause]
Hallelujah we are about like a little
over an hour in and I am wondering what
the overall cohesive narrative is
ultimately going to amount to though
yeah I kind of just feel like I've been
watching like some interesting
highlights over so far an interesting
character study highlight re showcasing
how petulance and idiocy could just get
you all the way to the top yeah I'm like
is this going to be a rise and fall kind
of movie or something or is this going
to take us to the Pinnacle just to drive
the point home but I'm half worried
we're just watching like a sequence of
events happening yeah without any real
sort of strong narrative yeah structural
end point yeah you suggest divorce after
years of debate you can see that it has
me divided I not ambitious I've never
declared war with
anyone you are the greatest leader in
the history of the world and the world's
only chance at peace this guy's this
guy's so smart he knows he has to like
tout his ego yeah he needs to gas him up
security of the Empire and peace in the
world depends upon an hand even if he
doesn't believe it he's just trying to
control the situation he could just have
an affair with another woman can't he
probably child count I mean I'm sure he
could fudge all the you know rules and
or what information gets out and make it
work yeah change the law that only can
be heirs I'm going to war to defend our
people and my wife cannot provide me an
air wow what a thing to bring up in
front of everyone if you do not bear me
a child tonight there will be a divorce
damn Jesus this is a private
conversation hasn't been enough love
making in this home to Bear a child
ow there have been years of it years
smash every all every day and with more
than just me wow this is really
uncomfortable you're empty you're fat I
enjoy my
meals dad bud get
it are you warmed
up man this guy's just like Elvis
Presley from the Priscilla movie
yeah it's my favorite Elvis I love your
talent and your taste and while I'm away
I will miss your grace and your dignity
how many poems you read to inspire that
line look I'm always here for you
Francis but I must admit I'm overwhelmed
with the excitement of the battlefield I
should not deceive you Alexander this
battle against him will be brutal and
terrifying oh but it will be great for
the camera it'll be righteous that'll be
what we showed up
for
aets I don't know anything about him p
in but this movie portrays him in kind
of a f in a really fascinating light he
a Manchild that when it came down to it
he knew how to get the job done seemed
like he always lived up to the word yeah
he knew his fascism boy on this day we
celebrate the first anniversary of our
coronation my previous Ally has now
joined with my enemy damn our Alexander
joined forces with the prince of Austria
yes I have heard that he's been studying
The Art of War sunu sunu yeah he tries
to copy me a little boy who will make a
terrible mistake I'm going to do the
opposite of everything I am certain I
will bring the Laurels of another
glorious Victory to my Army today
Napoleon back watch so many different
locations we've been going
to this isn't going to be great for
y'all seems like whenever they have to
go to war with England they have to
always take down the Allies
first everything's different when you're
going to fight
Russia
interesting I wonder what that code is
that means we're ready to attack Your
Majesty we are discovered never mind
discovered tell the men to rest gives me
an excuse so keep my eyes closed yeah
doing my meditations i n f infantry i m
t INF FJ
IM man the horrors of that where you
have to just just rise to the occasion
of War just relaxing one minute well and
and to be far enough back in time that
it's like hey the the opposing enemies
coming how far away are they all right
keep resting though we we need you at
your
best like it must not feel real until it
actually is happening yeah so you can
see the whites of their
eyes or just the ranks of their
formation this this is pretty
formidable opening fight a gladiator was
in the snow let them think they have the
higher
ground they got all this fog to work in
their
advantage it's poor horses man it's made
a lot of dead horses this was a terrible
time to be a
horse wowe attack these hay
[Music]
bales oh
jeez there's that Zoom send in the
Infantry take their position on the
higher ground have the
double uh way to cook let's cook let's
cook
yes yeah Circle them in this are
beautiful visual effects the scope and
scale is truly captured wow like it
feels real yeah from the West here's
their
place with them Flags out
now go after them yeah run
away
wow staging of these sequences no I like
these little nuggets of real
life yeah I figured there you go use
that
ice so at
ease wow what a shot
wowe
yeah oh y' done for the action is the
best thing about the movie yeah it is
gripping oh I love that blood smeared in
the ice water blood in the
water a poor
horse a that's sad oh boy oh boy s like
some Mel Gibson War violence here yeah
can you imagine Mel Gibson is Napoleon
wow what a sequence holy
[__] that is maximizing your artillery
it's a Slaughter I mean every time and
place to fight is is horrific but like
you you watch this era and you're just
like oh what misery this must have been
like oh man you're just like drinking in
the blood at that point yeah at
everybody on the surface just getting
mangled off the ice withraw
but everyone's got such cool helmets cut
off their
Retreat make an example out of them wow
dude
wow I can't tell what's CGI and what's
not other than like some of the
cannonballs but this all looks real like
the
explosions
Jesus oh my God cut off their Retreat
don't even let them surrender it's a
little literal Slaughter Francis so nice
to finally meet you so nice to finally
meet you H where am I ask is Alexander
are we waiting for his arrival before we
get started he will be joining us he's
beside himself with rage he says
[__] I realize I must compliment you
for making me commit an enormous error
an error huh what error have you made to
be speaking with you here and accepting
this invitation for peace I have not
followed up my victory no I could have
taken the whole Russian and Austrian
Army prisoners
yes
toast it's so weird because there
anything but intimidated yeah but this
is yeah it's like it's the luck of
living in a time and place where it's so
easy to craft and manipulate like it's
they capture it in a way like this is
just what he does yeah you know like I
don't really feel like we're really more
into the mindset of Napoleon or why
Napoleon is the way he is or how he
became to be this genius in the
battlefield like all these things that
like this movie kind of keeps you at a
distance on the biopic side of it and it
just portrays it like this is just
something he
does his job yeah totally it just
illustrates like you know in this time
and place the the minations exist to
where a guy like this can just Waltz his
way to the top he just seems like so
effortless at it at at this like RIS at
the when it comes to the battlefield
stuff like we don't really see the
struggle or anything we will conduct a
very practical experiment oh my thank
you mother waiting for you undressed
ready to for see his 18-year-old Elanor
denel de plena oh you can just
impregnant her there you go she's
brunette with brown eyes and the object
of this hardly unpleasant task is to see
if you can father a child are you going
to have an equal test for Josephine is
it Josephine or is it her we will have
an answer to this ni agging question of
who is keeping who from an heir to the
throne of France who is keeping you from
your Napo
baby it's not the same that's a
supportive mom yeah it's the mom who's
going to have your back mhm frankly I
don't feel like Mrs Humphrey would do
the same you know you'd be surprised I
would be surprised when you are one of
my subjects you will regret making that
[Music]
remark a buddy
oh mood lighting so he can imagine her
you think so I think he really just is
like head over heels for Josephine and
so you made her
pregnant damn just like that do even
care they do like cut through time in a
way it's like this is so weird to me
yeah sometimes they give you like a
subtitle to tell you what you're just
like we're yeah like if you didn't
without that line of dialogue I would
just assume that he came right back out
to the
party if I succeed in making the birth
of a boy that I shall call my own son I
want you as a witness to pretend the
confinement of the empress youranus you
are asking me to lie about the status of
the mother of your Heir yes yeah dude no
one's going to find out I cannot contain
that which I know to be the truth and
painful though it is the truth is that
the the empress is no longer capable of
bearing you a child ouch how did that
happen wow just married the 18-year-old
yeah Chuck the old one out into the snow
my good Josephine you know how I've
loved you it is you to you alone that I
owe the few moments of happiness I have
known in this world my destiny is more
powerful than my will wow my affections
must yield to the interests of my
people the Imperial decree the
dissolution of the marriage between the
Emperor Napoleon and the empress Joseph
wow that is a horrible cuz she could not
bear a child my people desire that this
Throne where Providence has placed me
would be given to my children however I
have lost hope of having children from
my marriage oh my god oh this is so mean
I've then been led to listen only to the
good of the state and to want the
dissolution years of my life this is my
burden you heard have embellished my
life for 15 years the memories of which
will remain forever etched in my heart
sure our marriage has become an obstacle
for the prosperity of
France she has been deprived of one day
being governed by the descendants of a
man brought To Us by Providence to
menend the evils of a terrible
Revolution oh Jesus and restore Faith
the throne and the social order oh my
God you're ruining our God where we
started versus where we are
[Music]
now this is this is for your country
that's what this is right whoa this is
so
humiliating yeah our marriage has become
an obstacle for the prosperity of France
agreeing to the disolution of our
marriage as I must does not change my
feelings slap will damn I love the
stifling laughter from her the emperor
will have in me always his his truest
friend oh I could still keep her around
in some way as my affection
slave this guy has no idea how to
process emotions you have just
pronounced the word which separates us
forever your mistaken ambition has ever
been and will continue to be the guide
of all your actions he could have had
true love you can never doubt the
sincerity of my wishes for your
happiness really yours thank you
Josephine dude you get to go back back
to you know your pick of the litter
you're good unless I'm missing a
horrible history fact yeah she's going
to get assassinated right here
Cannonball just rips through blows her
head
off I thought she had children yeah
maybe I don't know maybe he cast them
out into the street is he visiting her
right away
yep jeez I miss you it's been four years
has it what what movie my child is about
to ascend the
throne youve shown such great curse so
far so brave you are in being without me
do not permit yourself to fall into
Melancholy I feel like we'll get like a
scene with like a great like oh here we
go good ending and then then we do like
this jump like oh we could have like and
then there will be another SLE with the
drama yeah will you write me tomorrow
mhm and the next day the day after that
like as an edit it's trimmed it's paced
well for an edit uh at the same time you
could tell that like shit's been totally
cut out yes oh sure yeah yeah like they
make it it's paced well like the pace is
consistent um but it is there is stuff
like like he said you French you fight
only for money while we English we fight
for Honor oh here we go I replied
everyone fights for what they
lack this is not your story this never
happened to you did it that was a sick
burn we have the same saying with my
people in the turke oh no would be my
absolute pleasure and honor if I could
call you my brother is he does he have
like a Russian accent there is a way for
you to call me brother last night my
dinner I was Charmed by your sister oh
wow she's to be married to the Duke of
oldenberg I'm afraid well intervine
Napoleon yeah is there a formal offer
for Anna she is 10 well you see and Anna
she's 15 years old that is a
detail he is Elvis Presley yes yes all
great men are our friendship is built on
our mutual distrust of when we hold to
the Continental blockade we choke them
from the trade and we fight for our most
sacred rights that is what is important
between us I've just had a thought write
this down imagine an army marching about
way of Constantinople into Asia would
have only to reach the Euphrates to make
England tremble and bring her down on
her knees before the continent dope did
you have a pleasant journey it was
wonderful thank you do you need a bigger
hat she seems a amored by him you're
quite PE I'm not accustomed to that CU
Napoleon short how do I look to you do I
resemble my portrait
yes even more handsome and strong oh oh
my would you like to see the
bedroom yes would I oh my God she seems
way more into him come my child
bride the child your majesty your son
which one put him
[Music]
there what's going on
outside oh no that robe
though come meet my baby why are you
doing this dude oh because does she
still owes him a baby for love man that
is so
[Music]
mean
a can you raise this for me I want a
different one make this a king yeah I
want a different one you could have this
one you will understand what I have
sacrificed for you when you watch a
Ridley Scott movie
yes my dear Josephine I'm sad today
still rites to her SAR Alexander has
turned against me and forced me to
invade Russia he's decided to open his
ports to England wow I must wipe away my
Melancholy and begin the march to Moscow
just the types we and so I command the
combined forces of France Austria Italy
Germany and Poland sometimes they just
feel like they don't let enough things
sit yeah we got a director's cut to
maintain that was I was like oh man
we're getting somewhere like every time
it has me it's like just
and is this to a part of the war 182 the
war stuff are so visually interesting
but in terms of emotional heft to add to
the story it's just kind of just turn it
doesn't really thrust anything it's just
like oh here we are it's not the exact
right word but it is like the more
repetitive element because once you're
back out in battle you're just watching
a battle it's definitely like engaging
when it's happening but it doesn't
really add to the doesn't feel like it's
developing the story uh yeah the
emotional experience in the chair
oh
wow
ruthless oh he's got a a little bit of
horse riding form on
him oh my
[Music]
God
that excellent profile shot this is
epic whoa 28,000 they lose that battle
my dear Josephine I'm writing to you
because I've just won a great battle
today they won okay did they dude this
dude's always coming out on top Moscow
is now only 200 miles away and I think
of you all the WoW all yours I think
he's just telling himself so yeah they
they're not winning [__] right now oh he
lost okay but he needs this to yeah he
needs to convince himself by telling
her the grave
[Music]
of at least he still survived run in
battle like that and walking out of life
yeah where are
you oh boy where are you 300,000 Souls
live in the city and they've all just
left
where is
everybody
boy let's get some John Woo action in
here they all just Retreat from him I
think this is a
trap they is this her way of
surrendering it's not very sporting is
it for his honor in Russia is not mine
yeah I suppose so Birds [__] all
over this throne
uhoh wow God damn rather just burn it
all to the
ground that a hell of a shot though wowe
who did this they did they'd rather not
no they did not be sensible no they
would do it they are spting you sir your
majesty they
did God
he'd rather burn his own city than
negotiate with me I didn't think he had
the courage called this courage yep
we'll get to St Petersburg and have him
burned that too you're just going to
walk into town yep we have let too much
time step away we would be marching into
the Russian winter good if we go back to
Poland we can wait out the winter
month yeah they're counting on this
remember that I alone know your health
your fears I thank you as tenderly as is
I Will Always Love You Josephine my
friend Josephine it's like he's winning
but not really it is strange to write
that word to you you have always been so
much more you've always been my ba we
are
winning it's one way put Fortune has
abandoned me I know that it is what Fate
has for me your words rattle in my head
I am nothing without you does he have
any relationship with his current wife
not that we got to see it's in that 4our
cut of the 600,000 men you sent to
Russia only 40,000 have returned
therefore you have been Exile oh damn
jeez that's 560,000 deaths the Allied
Coalition of Austria Prussia Russia and
England and with the agreement of the
French Council Grant you sovereignty of
the island of Elba Elba dude it's your
Birthright a revenue of 2 million Franks
from the French f fund pensions for the
bonapart family and the empress Mar
Louise what a severance package that is
yeah it also provides for Empress
Josephine to retain all of her
properties an a lotted annual income of
1 million Franks what a severance
package Jesus but it was never really
about the money was it no no he did it
for passion all I've desired was its
glory and would never bring our
Misfortune oh you already did they want
me to
abdicate fine I'll abdicate
wow wow and I I wonder that must be
real it's the other thing too is he's
talked so much across this movie about
his people and his love for the people
and the people's love for him and we
almost never see just the regular people
of friends oh yeah
know yourness and oh my God I would load
if she gets pregnant with his
kid you do not have to lock yourself
away just because he's not here I know
what it is like to be
underestimated and your spirit it isn't
there it is yours and you can use it
empowering ass [__] right
there oh
[Music]
no he's still in his uniform nah he's
pathetic dear Josephine you are mine you
will always be I cannot stand it any
longer
longer it has been 300 days on this rock
and I'm ready to come home and reclaim
what's mine Jesus you and France dear
Josephine you still ain't called a root
I hope you had a chance it's been 300
days in the last two minutes John yep
yes it
has he Ain lying this this could have
been a mini
series freaking like his History Channel
highlights
oh now bring me my water slide open your
mouth
please why is she poisoned or
pregnant she must got uh what was the
ashes ashes We All Fall Down oh she's
got the plague my suggestion is to stay
in bed she's got some disease the flu
thingy she get tuberculosis tuberculosis
that's
and is it illegal for Napoleon to step
foot here sure I would imagine unless we
missed something but he was exiled he
seems like he's just yeah de gaffing and
coming back a ship landed on the beach
in on this morning and they are on the
March Napoleon bonapart is marching
towards Paris who's with
him a delightful Fanfare this is all for
Napoleon General Marshall in defense of
the Royal government of King Louis VI
18th request that you surrender your
weapons and cease your March so that you
may be arrested and return to your
Island will you please inform the
general that I should like to come and
speak with him I have no fight with my
own Fifth
Army still done a lot for them yeah you
know I mean that's why they're giving
him the severance he wishes to speak nah
ready yeah yeah we done talking bro and
that's how Napoleon
died soldiers of the fifth regiment do
you recognize me I am your daddy do you
recognize me soldiers yes Emperor oh
dude he got one loyalist I miss you I'm
Melancholy for my home bored as hell and
for our victories together yeah he did
give us
victories I want to come home will you
join
me the hell just happened says like four
sentences oh my
God uh this is going be real bad news
but damn that influence he held wow sure
some variation of this happened but yeah
damn all I guess King Louis the 18th I
really earned their respect he led them
to a lot of Victories and he was always
out there in the field yeah he wasn't
just chilling at home bonded to these
guys make France great again on May 6 Dr
Cove as I was called and found her chest
congested her throat inflamed her
illness was dip theia diptheria ah what
was that on May 29th last Sacrament was
given and she died oh I didn't even get
to see her and no one thought to notify
me it would it was illegal at the time
sir do
you you blame me he just always makes it
a about of himself
yeah of course you
don't not to Bear the burden of
responsibility this
narcissist this Nar I want the letters
that I wrote to her I'm sorry I don't
have them they were stolen by her valy
wow where did she keep them yeah same
tissue in the cupet in her Petro next to
her bed next to her heart I'm sorry I
forgive you I forgive you do you blame
me of course not I forgive
you he knows his place in the world
Jes this Congregation of allies shall
form along the borders of France and
Belgium an army the muscles from
Brussels 120,000 troops from Prussia
This Vermin has routed the farmyards of
Europe are the farmers snort ouch we
should have struck this blow long ago no
where's your loyalty lie man I believe I
speak for all of us when I say that the
only regret we all share is that we
allowed This Vermin to live at all wowe
I wish we got to see more of that stuff
you were talking about
125,000 men and 100,000
men against our
125,000 men this is a fight on land so
we could take them Britain does not know
how to do that I know strike quickly
against Wellington defeat them
separately disallow them from uniting
forces here
waterloop home of the excellent water
slide
es morning so he just like assumed
command yeah enough people faithful to
him they were able to just didn't have
to go any work arounds with the whole I
mean they are the the enforcers so if
enough people are just like we follow
this guy what you go to war yeah I mean
water I I believe water L is not going
to end well but but also why would you
ruin that John I don't know this is my
guess I'm just judging by where we are
in the movie this is all like we're in
into history I didn't even know about
like I didn't know he came back from
Exile and like got his troops back and
tell him make the rain
stop right yes sir right we we'll get
right on that now listen very carefully
patience we must hold this ground let
him come to
us oh
boy get a little nap in now there he is
he appears to be just sleeping
appearances can't be receiving I have
the emperor in my sight do I have
permission to fire certainly not
General's commanding armies have better
things to do with their time to shoot at
one another hold your fire Rifleman on
pain of death
wow at 11 to 12 miles I want to report
every hour yes pler p on the road 12
miles come on Napoleon Prussian troops
have been sighted in the road ready the
[Music]
cannons the looks the rain is stopped
sir you boys did good stop the rain God
is on our
[Music]
side patience patience with Pati
everyone be patient so eye the ball and
get out of the
way that one drummer just got
dusted
infantry this seems like a terrible idea
yeah that patience going to come in
handy
[Music]
now oh not the Cannons I cannot imagine
being on a battle field like
[Music]
this
a wow willhelm
scream oh the amount of dudes exploding
in this
movie isn't high but it it's high enough
to catch me by surprise every
time no he's losing his confidence man
the Duke of
Wellington prepare to receive Cavalry
prepare to
[Music]
receive hold
our Stand Fast to the last man we must
not be beat
absolutely holy
[__] oh
boy oh oh my
God whoa what do you call this formation
say it in the name of the
emperor this is terrible plan
Jesus oh my
god get back in
the
yeah just doesn't have the same old ring
as it used to go die Napoleon go die n
he can't die until they play the ABBA
song wow man that's a hell of a
formation they got
wow man what choreographer you got for
the horses and everything to keep this
all in formation it's
impressive
wow
wa how did they get that shot
it better be an SPCA certification on
this he looks so tired you are the brave
of
as Never
Surrender for homand and Glory he's
going to
die wow dude
wow
it is exhausting being a Sher left's
[Music]
hand everyone just gets like a great
shot everyone who get shot just falls
down forward you know they're not like
ah yeah dead there's instant death
everyone maybe that helps though maybe
no matter how bad your adre is maybe you
just lay down and hope that you know I
would just fall on once I fire just fall
as lay still as you can until this is
all over and then crawl
away God what a
mess what a mess Cavalry Advance sir
Cavalry Advance they really do capture
the the epicness in these War scenes a
lot yeah I just like the high body count
the
tangibility how close and personal it
all is such a there's such a roar to it
nice little jab with the stab
yeah actual body
count he can't help himself yeah know
he's going to die right
now thank
God sure God's not here man he's busy
come to our Marshal of
friend yeah they all are just r to
die whoa whoa
dude cut him off at the retreat don't
let him Retreat
yeah oh
damn wow
Plymouth the first battle we've seen him
lose I guess yes or like truly outright
lose yeah it is geometry I simply know
precisely where to place a cannon but
tragically I cannot transfer this
knowledge to my
Marshals what is most difficult in life
Fair accepting the failures of others
yep must not do that yep man did not
grow at all what are they doing there
it's the M shipment they adore him get
him out your grace morning General his
boys are delightful and this breakfast
now I know why you have such a
successful
Navy unit runs on its stomach I've never
visited the English Countryside imagine
I love the kwals and my dear sir it is
only by a narrow margin of opinion that
you have been spared the fate of being
shot I'm afraid it's impossible for the
British government to allow you to stay
in England is she just like vacationing
right now yep you permitted three
officers and 12 servants to accompany
you into exile
Exile will be contained to the island of
St Helen oh my God under the watchful
eye of Governor Hudson L and his family
would it be better in My Last Exile it's
a small island more of a rock really a
thousand miles from the mainland of
Africa W it's even worse don't have time
to reflect
sure that your presence verify twice
daily by the orderly officer you will
have an anklet on your
ankle
seems like his greatest losses started
coming in the form of when he lost
Josephine yeah behind every Great
Dictator it's a great woman I hate to
see you alone my sweet stubborn Emperor
I let you loose and let you come to ruin
next time I will be Emperor and you will
do as I say yes
mommy could be worse yeah you are right
every night I beg to see you in my
dreams and when I do you turn me away
flies and the
wine can I tell you what I have waiting
for you it is a secret and I will show
you when you arrive come to me Napoleon
that's just water let's try this again
go die get that poison going look at
this Godfather three shot right
here
died on the 5th of May 1821 after 6
years of
Exile 61
[Laughter]
battles oh my God oh my
God one day
excellent where's the French who that uh
I guess just the French alone how many
other
casualties oh
boy I'm assuming it was a French who
died in that list because it said in um
one of them that 460,000 died and he
said that they returned to troops with
only 40,000 so after sting in
500,000 so 500,000 minus 40,000 400
60,000 okay before he got exiled it said
500,000 troops were sent and only 40,000
returned was it 500,000 that time I I'll
Trust I'll I'll Trust your recollection
very specific
number
damn that's
wild I mean yeah like either way whether
it's combined or if it's just French
it's still like
insane and I mean that 460,000 was like
what their combined resources across
their allies right is there a post
credit scene all right reject Nation so
today I want to share something with you
that has been a wonderful addition to my
health and fitness journey that I
discovered during the holidays and that
is liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm
down to my very last packet and I'm
freaking out but it's okay I got more in
the mail now a lot of you have been so
kind to notice how I've been working on
my physical health thank you for all the
compliments and one thing I learn is
that proper hydration is absolutely
crucial especially post-workout and
pre-filming after post-workout and my
wife actually introduced me to this
product which is perfect because we not
only care about quality but a good taste
and quality product we it's after a
sweaty workout or just after you know a
good night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products
that fit that description that also
taste good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IVs hydration multiplier is in
summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers
hydration into your bloodstream faster
and more efficient than water alone cuz
sometimes drinking a whole gallon is not
always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water I'm also
big on efficiency plus it's packed with
love essential vitamins and we know
vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy
free you can customize the water amount
to your taste again perfect for post
night recovery traveling or just having
a big night out you know what I mean
noral so if you want to boost your
support for the Channel and boost your
hydration game go to liquid i.com and
use promo code Rejects at checkout
that's liquid i.com promo code Rejects
and remember liquid IV it's not a real
IV but sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
well gang if you made it to this point
we just finished watching Ridley Scotts
Napoleon why don't you leave some five
star reviews on that Apple music or
Spotify wherever you might be listening
to this and uh we're going to hop into
our thoughts on the
movie unless we have anything else to do
first unless there's anything that we
ought to dictate to people yeah no okay
well damn uh this has been an
interesting year for movies like this
this this is uh you know a big sweeping
epic of sorts but it's also got a very
sort of
ironic quality at the center of it and
having seen funny killers of the flower
moon is here on screen they want us to
watch it after the Hunger Games and
after the brick layer in that order um
but that
movie kind
of makes for an interesting compliment
to me because these are two of the most
striking and and you know talked about
movies of the Year from two veteran
filmmakers that both
showcase
like what can happen when just like
horribleness and and conniving
is left to kind of its own devices and
and when you're in a time where like
information is restricted so you have
you know both the immense possibility of
what you know minations can do and also
just like idiocy and and pettiness can
do and whereas Killers is a very austere
very straight movie I felt like this
endeavored to explore similar territory
obviously with a different historical
context uh but but with a much more
deeply ingrained sense of yeah irony
humor Etc uh but yeah what what you
think
sir
um my nice side is just wanting to say
mixed bag
sure cuz I can easily pinpoint what I
liked about it yes see it's easy for me
to like isolate what I really like about
it it's very easy overall I'm not sure I
like this movie sure to be to sure sure
uh overall I'm not sure I like this
movie uh I think it it it kind
of it just felt way edited down and the
I I don't really find the story
itself that enriching of a story it's
more like I watched a bunch of things
happen even Napoleon himself doesn't
really
have uh things happen for and to
Napoleon but him as a character doesn't
really have a real descent as a as a
person or an arc in any real way like he
kind of just starts off this way and
he's a little bit more that guy by the
end of it yeah it's not exactly much of
a uh in terms of a narrative I think
it's it's kind of weak and and and then
like we like we're saying throughout the
whole reaction that it just kept feeling
really paired down like with the way
they would handle time jumps and time
spans and then you would have scenes
that were like oh this is kind of like
uh emotionally dramatically I'm I'm into
it and then we're just sometime
sometimes we'll do a time Jump without
foring you we've done a Time jump or
they they do a time Jump and they inform
you and then it would ultimately lead to
like battle scenes that were really
grandiose uh epic and on scale and shot
with such visceral nature that I haven't
seen in any of the 2023 movies to this
degree especially in a practicality
scale where it would blend CGI in ways
that at times other than like Cannon and
maybe some fire that I couldn't really
tell but like this like those battle
sequence were just beyond epic U at the
same time when I would step back I would
go but I I have like no emotional
investment in in this fight I don't know
the soldiers all the stuff about what
Napoleon cares about outside of
Josephine I don't really know uh this
this rency for France I don't understand
then he there's a lot of things that are
been like dictated to me and told to me
but again it was kind of like watching a
a a history book it
was with questioning constantly what is
real what what is accurate and what is
not accurate uh because and the reason
why I would do that is because I wasn't
lost enough in the narrative to not give
a [__] about that sure I was so aware of
uh a lot of the shortcomings that this
movie was doing and like the first hour
I would be like I know I'm enjoying this
there's there's a bit of a farsal
element as we were pointing out and this
humorous Touch where they would use
music to that would be in in a fun jued
position where it was like this
classical Elegance while like atrocities
are taking place and it would magnify uh
some of the goofiness and silliness and
how these people were kind of a joke it
magnifies the yeah the the weird
artifice of high society in a time
especially such as this where it's like
conflict is so tangible but it lost that
sure that humor it lost it lost all that
for me uh in the last like hour and a
half of this film or something some some
part of that runtime the one of the
things that was really clicking for me
and then it just starts becoming like we
got to just clip through this and clip
through this and clip through this and
out of two and a half hours I didn't
really feel anything when I was watching
it I I was I was watching certain times
I would I would admire something I'm
watching or i' be like oo that's I might
react to like a violent
scene um or I might oh he was kind of an
[__] here uh but
I I think like the storytelling itself
is is one of the things that I can have
an issue with rly Scott movies nowadays
like sometimes he comes out with a
banger um and then other times it comes
out with stuff that just kind of feels
like it's pretty it's great to look at
Great cast um but in terms of like your
overall story there's not much of an
impact and I think the impact maybe
there's historians who watch this and
are like oh but seeing this BR maybe
that like tickles your fancy in some way
but from just a movie goinging
experience I think it's kind of empty
and that's my biggest issue with it is
that uh I I didn't latch on to anything
and it
was never even cold in a way that was um
appealing like I like a cold harsh movie
I like I like watching the bad guy be
the main character I I love all those
kinds of film FMS you know but there's a
a a there's still a voice and a and a
pull from the heart that it has to have
and and and I felt like this
was I just think it was edited down and
sure yeah and I imagine there's an
exceptional is there you kept saying
this thing about a longer Cut Is there
is there a thing about a longer cut yeah
yeah there's going to be like a 4H hour
version of this
movie yeah that like shows yeah but
unlike Rebel Moon where I'm like really
like I'm not really sure I want to see a
longer cut I'd be curious to see a
longer cut of this one I would I would
be I'll watch the rebel Moon cut but I
well in the rebel moon it's obvious it's
appears obvious as to what might get put
back in whereas this you're sort of like
other than fleshing out certain beats of
history that maybe fly by you know
there's a it seems like there's a
broader array of things that that extra
time could a lot for you know rather
than clearly there were PL elements
removed you know yeah I think this
lacked strong characterization and and
and I keep going back to the word
narrative it's just at the end of the
day you have to tell a story and and so
even if it's a slice of life or
something you have to tell the story
there's got to be some kind of narrative
here and it I guess we technically watch
the rise and fall of Napoleon but the
way they would handle the the time when
you would jump around time and then what
you chose to focus on in those times
and you see what they have at their
hands at disposal when it comes to a
budget that like oh yeah you could
easily probably have like other scenes
on The Cutting Room floor that really
got you hooked into stuff whether it be
from just a the Mind intellectually is
more interested or the heart is more
invested and to me this movie kind of
didn't either after like two and a half
hours I was just watching stuff happen
with occasionally being amused by
walking Phoenix's performance and and
admiring Vanessa Kirby's work but out of
a big cast I mean like I can't really
name anyone else other than them but
there's a lot of people here like no one
really stands out as a performer sure
walking Phoenix kind of felt like again
because of the the story they presented
it's it it it's not really I don't feel
like I got to know Napoleon really yeah
I got to know some things about Napoleon
sure some stuff that maybe people like
rumored about what he was like as a
person I can tell how this movie feels
about Napoleon but I never got into the
mind of Napoleon I never got into why
Napoleon really is the way he is it's
just things that were alluded to it it
never felt like it got confident enough
to embrace a a voice or his perspective
you know like it that's where I felt
like it was at odds were like I could
feel I could feel the Judgment of Ridley
Scott of the story here but in never
quite took the perspective of Napoleon
when that's what the movie's doing is
telling it from the perspective of
Napoleon while occasionally cutting to
someone else um yeah it doesn't really
extrapolate on his perspect it's like
you understand his perspective and since
it's being
told largely from his diluted point of
view it's like you know yeah there's
there I I can see the value in doing
that and I can see why you would want to
pitch it that way for a movie like like
this but I do think that other elements
would have to kind of change a bit to
really complement that or to make it
feel like it isn't just you know two and
a half hours of watching like a terrible
narcissist never learn and just you know
parade around the world being petulant
and and and yeah like it it is it is an
interesting it's one of these movies and
and I'm not going to I'm trying not to
harp on it too much but there are
elements of this experience that do kind
of remind me of the debate that I've
heard and and been somewhat a part of
when it came to killers of the flower
mov it's like both of these movies have
this quality where like when you get
what the movie's
doing you get what the movie's doing and
and and this movie especially doesn't
really deviate a whole lot from the
thing that it's doing which is to
present Napoleon this guy who has this
status in history who clearly was able
to do uh great and devastating things in
equal often simultaneous measure
um and there's something obviously
interesting about that in Jos to our
current Society we have many a Napoleon
figure at large in politics and
otherwise here today you know obviously
you can draw your through line to Trump
if you want to with the movie like this
but it is that thing of like okay so I
can imagine that really working for
somebody for Two Plus hours and
certainly I feel like this movie like it
this is a potentially like a hole is not
as great as the sum of the parts cuz all
the parts are pretty great it's like all
the performances really committed all of
the designs the way that it lives in
this time in place to really sell the
tangibility and the harshness and the
contrast between high society and all
the ceremonial stuff that people like to
stand on especially in this moment in
time and they even highlight it on
occasion you know polite society and the
the you know extreme depravity that can
be you know propped up on top of that or
you know any number of other atrocious
human elements but yeah it's like the
movie doesn't position itself to
extrapolate on why Napoleon is as as you
mentioned or to it's weird it's like you
don't have to show him sympathetically
and it would be a different kind of
movie if you did Endeavor to show things
that explain why he is how he is um but
yeah it's like as it exists here and now
I can easily see a lot of viewers
getting to the end and being like okay
that was a lot of miserable and a lot of
ironic but yeah what is this amounting
to beyond all of that plus you know a a
quick Sprint through history that I
imagine will probably Pace a little
differently and perhaps a little more
Brea thebly for people who know the
history well um but yes for for the rest
of us who are either Rusty or or
ignorant toward a lot of the greater
details it does feel like whoa okay wait
hold on we're hopping through time and
even the way they leave the some of the
titles on the screen that are explaining
things to you are like pretty quick and
moving along and uh yeah yeah it is one
where it's like there's so much to
appreciate but what it's giving you you
know if you especially if you see it
from early on and that's not enough for
you I feel like this would be a very
long experience for a lot of people no I
I think I was just
watching facts or depictions of things
uh the entire time you know if you if
you look at a movie
like I don't know uh There Will Be Blood
uh for example right um that movie is a
really harsh cold mean movie about one
guy who starts off greedy and he's even
greedier by the end and but he's left
lonely and miserable and he's getting
worse and you're watching this guy like
deteriorate into a monster you know like
it's hopelessness for that man by the
end and what he's lost himself to in the
pursuit of more and he's he's completely
lonely and and here I use that as a
comparison because there's at least like
a mood about that there's a there's at
least like a terror about that and
you're you're watching the effect it has
on other people like really living in
that watching how other people get lost
in the vortex of this man and here I I
feel like they they say things like like
the one guy when he's like his egotism
and uh the way he rules is like the the
Paul the dark Paul that he cast over I'm
like all this [__] like I don't really
feel like I saw any of that I don't
really feel like I got any of that of
what it was what he was like really what
he was like as a general other than you
watch the battle happen you don't really
see him his mindset as a general um you
don't really see what he's like as a
ruler as an emperor you don't really see
all these things that there saying that
he does that are terrible cuz I'm like
from what you've shown me I I would be
like other than him conquering I I'm not
really getting any additional context to
understand what he's done that's made
him so such a polarizing figure what's
made him so terrible other than he he
left people down I'm not really being
fed that you know and I'm not seeing why
again everything comes back to why right
you you got to you got to show not tell
and this movie relied a lot on
occasionally dro some nuggets of
information to make you go here's why
when you you have to let the audience
marinate in some like um whatever it may
be atrocities or the love that you see
that he has and I think the time where
they gave the most delicacy was the
thing they were like placing all their
eggs in one basket for was this tragic
romance with uh this Josephine woman uh
which yeah was probably the most
interesting part to me and the movie
treats It Like It's the Most most
interesting part about his character and
I I think they lose sight of that like
it's it's kind of it's a to me it's a
disjointed experience it's it lacks
focus and it doesn't really know where
it wants to place it's hard and focus at
you can't just cut to a cool battle
scene like you can't you can't just tell
me like updates on what's going on you
know that's what this movie does it's
just like an update update the
experience update the timeline uh here's
what's happening and then and then
narrative becomes confusing on Dynamics
and relationships and stuff I I I like
what happened with his brother you know
there was a whole thing with his brother
like what his
brother yeah totally um that's something
I'm just remembering right now it and
and it's a big yeah I'm not I don't
think I like the movie I really don't
it's how it it it plays the concoction
of all these elements because on the one
hand I can see the there there's a lot
of the beginnings of a thread it's like
I get the use of the battles as they
juxtapose against the other scenes
because it's all this again when you're
just alone in some big ornate room and
it's people talking you know you're able
to really see the disconnect between
again how especially harsh and nasty War
at this point in time is uh and how you
know you're so far removed when you're
you know back home or in some great
Mansion plotting all this stuff
and yeah it's like you this that people
are behind him and his TR like part of
the reason the moment with the troops in
the wood toward the end right before
waterl kind of worked for me is because
I couldn't tell really what to expect
and I was like oh no he's not going to
win them back is he but I didn't have
really reason to go like I know that
these dudes are super dedicated to him
it was so like that
moment worked because of of that but at
the same time I feel like the rest of
the movie kind of suffers because of
that because yeah it's like you said we
don't really get to see the soldiers
even through his you can still do that
through his perspective but see him
being you know of those people and you
know rallying them to a point where
you're like well I see how dedicated
these people are or uh inversely like
throughout the movie he may he makes
mention to like the people for I'm doing
this for the people of France I the
people they love me they look to me and
we almost never see the people which
again is I think somewhat intentional
and somewhat of a fair choice because
it's illustrating how removed especially
in a time and place like this where
you're confined to just letters and what
you can see and what trusted people
relay to you like I get again the
purpose but as it's all executed here
into this Melting Pot it does feel kind
of impersonal and a little disconnected
at times and then you have the romance
element which again kind of reminded me
of a killers of the flower Moon thing
where you're watching this clearly toxic
bad situation go down but at the core of
it you're like but maybe in some weird
Twisted way they do love each other
although here while I did appreciate
those scenes and the Performing of them
I didn't think it was as strong or
interesting as say it was in Killers
because here a lot of those scenes are
like kind of the same scene just in
different years and after different
battles and I didn't
really I started to lose the plot in
terms of like I get what his feelings
are about her I can't tell what her
actual feelings are and like she'll
write these letters and part of my brain
is going okay I think there's got to be
a lot of ironic double speak in here but
she's still writing him and you know
they still maintain this contact and
even after all this and she's like
laughing at him during the divorce
proceedings I I guess she loved him
somehow but also I kind of don't buy it
and and and yeah you're left with the
muck of certain of these choices where
you're sort of like I don't really know
what what the choice fully was well I I
don't under I don't think they what
could have helped is if they if it
seemed like within the page time that
our characters were aging at all that
too and they they don't they don't I
don't feel like any time passes for our
performers like walking Phoenix and
Vanessa Kirby like they just look the
same yeah their hair changes but then
you're but but we also live in a time
where everyone's got like 20 wigs so
like yeah you get to the end and I was
starting to go okay like he I guess in
the right light he kind of looks like
older and more pale but I feel like
that's just kind of more got to do with
like the performance and the fact that
he's like kind of slowly giving up here
at the end you know rather than it's
actually being like a choice within you
know yeah that aspect of the the craft
the whole thing with like being exiled
and stuff like that first year he the
movie glosses over that when he's first
exiled he's he's exiled in this film's
runtime for like 5 minutes and I didn't
know as a part of History
I need to come back like I'm like what
in my time of experience I'm not saying
I need like an hour I'm saying that I
you this movie Just glosses over it and
he's like I'm tired I'm like well I in
my time I I feel like you just got here
you know and it's funny but I feel like
they could have still maintained that
the humorousness of that while also yeah
at least committing to it a little more
for so then a viewer like me can be
surprised when it's like oh I didn't
realize he was exiled once came out of
Exile tried to you know do one more coup
and then failed and then got super
exiled like I didn't realize the whole
water loop context that way so yeah yeah
I don't know you're right it's like
everything even though this is a movie
that again uh looks like a classical
painting and I like the contrast of how
it doesn't behave that way but but yeah
like there's a Grace uh of pace that I
don't think they quite nailed and I
wonder how I would feel if I didn't know
that this is supposed to be longer and
certainly again like a rebel Moon you
can tell without having to be told that
whereas this you know I might not have
known as well had I not been aware of
that but also I mean you know you could
have easily miniseries did
this yeah I don't think this should be a
like a story with this much time span
like I don't know how you could tell
this even in 4 hours I that's that that
honestly feels like it'd be better still
feels like might miss the mark with the
amount they want to tell it still feels
a little too I don't feels like a lot
for what this is trying to do yeah
you're trying to span a lot uh uh like a
little too much I think in when with the
amount you're trying to incorporate
because again even a movie like There
Will Be Blood you don't really know why
he is the way he is but they they give
you other things to really feed off of
and sink your teeth into and you spend
enough time with other characters to get
some of that development
yeah whereas here you know uh I don't
need to know exactly why he loves France
but to for it to really drive like a
wedge between the marriage so much and
then for his desire for more like I need
some conflict that truly arises from
that you know I need something more some
kind of personal Hollywood it up a
little bit would you something it's
moving quick enough that it just feels
like well this is just how he thinks so
naturally he just need to ascend to the
highest level of rule because this feels
this still feels like a movie you know
this still feels like a Hollywood film
it doesn't feel like oh I'm stepping
into a moment in time and that's okay
I'm totally okay with it feeling like a
film uh but if you're going to do that
then Hollywood say Hollywood it up then
create some drama create some real
conflict here do something to to give it
that extra that that little Sizzle so
that way that that way we're were on
board for some of the more dramatic
Journeys and stuff like that or or have
something to care about but I didn't
care about anything that was happening
man I I did not care like it is one of
those Cinema films where you go through
the first hour and you're like some
pretty cool some good craft on display
and then you get past a point and you're
like that Goodwill's worn up but this is
moving the at the same this is moving
with the same sensibility and it isn't
showing any sign of yeah of you know
picking up a thing or descending into it
thing it it seems like and especially
with a a character you know will have a
significant fall even if you don't have
the details it it does start to feel
like you're just going to kind of see a
collection of events until it's done
rather than feeling like you're going on
a journey that has a momentum of a story
like this needs a Martin scares he Touch
of of of a rise and fall of a of a of an
individual where you see like the glory
that he got to experience of why he'd
want that back yeah when he's like
talking with the children who admire him
like I got no sense of this world that
has been developed here that these that
that there would be children who would
want to like hear from him I got no
sense I'm like how I'm so confused on
the level of respect because I'm mainly
checking in with the other political
people who just dog this guy you know so
I'm I'm not really in tune with how
everyone else views him so that's why
when the soldiers do come around I'm
like oh this is kind of a surp oh my God
he's leading them into fighting with the
[__] you yeah I think this is a case
where you could benefit and hey rley
Scott I mean like respect to Ridley
Scott because again like half the time
he shows back up these days and I'm like
damn dude you be cranking out movies
like you know these if you spent maybe
all of that time on half as many movies
maybe they would all be a little bit
better but you know like he's a pro
obviously and and something like this
especially during the first half I was
like man though you know even at his age
and as long as he's been at this Ridley
is really you yeah and and it's a a
Marvel that this looks as good as it
does you know for again the fact that he
does stay so busy and it is as tangible
as it is like it feels dug into but yeah
like I don't associate him with the same
level of human thoughtfulness like you
know Ridley Scott stuff can be big on
ideas but I feel like and and just
continuing on this scorsi Touchstone
like I do feel like he is a filmmaker
who has a certain level of compassion
that can carry like even if you're
watching a killer of the flower Moon who
has a lead character and many of your
lead characters are like unsavory people
half of them
dumb and narcissistic and whatever else
there's still like you can tell that the
author of this is looking
compassionately at like how the humanity
of the situation got this way and I
don't feel like this movie has its eye
very much on that which I think I don't
need like a full like I personally got
to know the the tragedy of uh of
Napoleon like you know you can still be
a bit cynical or you can still be a bit
of a satire or a farce but I think yeah
that that humanist angle could have
helped to temper a lot of things across
this okay it's got a 58% critic score
59% audience score okay wow the critic
score and audience score are very much
in sync with each other sure yeah that
is very very much in sync yeah that's
like wild you never see that I I
actually expected one of them to be high
like significantly higher than the other
mhm oh that's low um I like the house of
gu that was all right oh I want to see
how so Gucci it's not ter I I didn't
mind it I didn't love it but I liked it
last duel I just can't find my can't
muster the strength to watch them I just
can't can't muster the strength to watch
it when I heard I'm like I don't know I
want to sit through that I just don't
want to sit through it and it's the one
movie like that too where I constantly
heard people going like actually those
of us who went saw it it's like it's
pretty it's one of his best and even
still I'm just like I still just don't
know if I'm going to if I even care I
just don't want to experience
that yeah like I for when this maybe in
like 10 or 15 years when we're far
removed from like the moment in time
that it was also co-opting to to come
into existence yeah but uh yeah I mean
damn made the Martian 2015 [__] I mean
yeah like must I mean according to Ryan
Tomato's last duel seem like his last
great film which was only in 2021 like
like his one that's like oh people think
this is a great movie you know yeah and
that's the thing is he hasn't gone to
that place yet where he like makes one
movie every six years so it it's like I
guess it's easier to look at Really
Scott as having lost the touch but then
be reminded like but every few movies he
has one that people are like this is at
least better than just good or maybe
even great so like you know I I'm torn
because I'm glad to see him still out
there still kicking and still you know
showing you know that he's got those
chops but also there are times where
yeah I feel like he his kogin liness of
the here and now maybe gets in the way
of something that could impact a little
bit more pressingly and and uh
permeating L so to speak yeah because I
mean clearly there's tons and tons of
artistry on
display um alrighty
well okay I'm good John yeah we're good
well gang what you guys think do you
love Napoleon now do you sympathize with
him leave us your thoughts what was your
favorite aw Contender of
2023 leave it in the C M M N T's and hey
before we get out of here let's do a
patron of the day shout
out Michael B omn media happy New Year
Michael B alrighty guys let me get this
out of the way he has a YouTube channel
called omn media where he does reactions
he's been on this channel with us I've
done a few movies with him to cover
tales of the Jedi John covered a mission
impossible with him one movie I said you
could have one one movie and Counting um
well you know what
man I think for 2024 this whole like
promoting you thing has to come to an
end far because your channel I'm seeing
is doing better now uh-uh and frankly I
got a hint of a being threatened why
would you do that to us this whole like
reactor community of we got to stick
together and help each other out yeah
yeah yeah it's all just a a bunch of of
of of figing pleasantries is what we do
but we all know that we want to dominate
one another and I don't care what kind
Deeds you've done I don't care how long
you've been pledged to our patreon page
your success is out of spite your [__]
has to end now all right do you be as
successful as you want but from here on
out no more plugging Omni media I will
not be shouting out o Emma and mother
and is and Nancy the number one media
I don't want to do that anymore because
watching your reactions to Reacher oh
SOA uh
Echo uh all the movies you've been
covering with these great looking
thumbnails and wonderful commentary and
then every time I open up your videos
and just see like man this guy gets like
nothing but positive comments because
he's that good I'm sick of talking about
it dude absolutely sick of promoting o
as an oh my God he's still here M as man
why do we still keep promoting him n as
in no we no longer promote omn media one
as in there can only be one like
Highlander and then media as in I'm
going to stop watching his media stop
watching the media yeah Omni media yeah
Omni
media but in in seriousness you
know succeed as much as you can oh yeah
and um you know come up with some goals
for this year yeah yeah yeah think of
how you can improve your operation
without uh you know out stripping
ours happy New Year you
[Music]
dick